su gentiloni sir president ladies and
gentlemen of the court appointed member
of the european commission by the council
of the european union following the vote
of approval of the european parliament
the solemn commitment to respect
in the performance of my duties
the treaties and the charter of
fundamental rights of the  the European Union to
perform my duties in complete
independence in the general interest of the
Union not to seek or
accept in the performance of my
duties instructions from any government
institution organ body to
refrain from any act incompatible with
the nature of my duties to
perform  of my duties
I note the obligation established by the
Treaty on the Functioning of the
European Union by virtue of which each
member state must respect this character and
not seek to influence the members
of the commission
in the performance of their duties I also
undertake to respect for  the
duration of my functions and after the
termination  one of these the obligations
deriving from my office and in
particular the duties of correctness and
discretion regarding
the acceptance after this termination of
certain functions or certain
benefits
[Applause]
macy